the new album is called this land and  this is the title track this whole song  is based on what has been happening and  that that of witnessed in the last few  years with the climate all the hatred  everyone at each other's throats just  it's a lot this was an honour of Gary's  new album Gary Clark jr.  [Music]  [Music]  I  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  pairen or the pit stop now that I got  the money 50 acres in tomorrow they ride  in the middle of drop country  [Music]  I'm up to something  I'm just eating now the steel  and this is my analogy I  Oh  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  I'm break me oh I can't let on  you can meet Mike on another knock only  if you wanna try it  the judge  [Music]  oh you think I want to something  I was still  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  yeah  [Music]  yeah  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  jumping  blowback where you  my  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]